The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: It's 1:06.
We're going to start
presentations at 1:10.
So Ghost Maze just get started.
You don't have to come
down here yet, but just
make sure you're ready.
So just a brief going over
what we're doing today.
Presentations, I hear a lot of
really good energy in the room.
So I hope to hear that when
you come down and tell us
about your games
and all the foibles,
all the things went wrong, all
the things that went right.
Hopefully this is a
really good prep for you
for our next
assignment, which is
going to be much, much longer.
So after we get through
with presentations,
we'll take a brief break.
And then we're going to just
jump right in to project 4.
I'll introduce
project 4 again, going
through all the boring
slides with all the deadlines
and stuff.
When I get to that, if you
want to fall on Stellar,
I just updated the
project for assignment
today to make sure that
the deadlines were correct.
And we'll double check
that again as well.
Unfortunately,
Pablo who came to us
in the beginning
of the semester,
is not here with us in person.
But he will be here
with us on Skype.
He's in Geneva
right now, but he'll
be talking to us about what
they're looking for project 4.
In particular, we're
going to be introduced
to six different game
topics, game design topics.
And you're going to
choose one of them.
We're not necessarily
making your choice today.
We're going to
brainstorming today.
have people form up
in a brainstorming groups
around these topics
to talk about them.
And then you will
have over the weekend
to talk about it on
the mailing list,
to read some of the resources
and some of the materials
we posted to Stellar
to see which topic
you're most interested in.
We're going to start the day
off Monday with forming teams.
So a little bit longer
time to form teams,
bit longer time to really
think about the topic
and think about what the
project's going to be-- again,
you have more time to actually
do concepting on this project.
It's an eight week project.
Nine weeks, if you count spring
break, which you shouldn't.
We designed it as an
eight week project.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Not spring break?
PROFESSOR 1: I said no.
Yeah don't work on spring break.
Like you were going to.
Any quick questions
before we start?
We've got two minutes left.
Any quick questions you
might have about project 3?
About turn ins?
AUDIENCE: What did you mean
[INAUDIBLE] spring break?
PROFESSOR 1: I said don't
work during spring break.
We designed this as
a eight week project.
Project 4 is an
eight week project.
We've designed it so
that you are not working
on a project over spring break.
What's that?
You could give me some
details about what
I'm screwing up over here.
So do we have a fall break?
Don't we have a week long break?
Thanksgiving break?
It's 70 degrees outside.
I'm in a different
place right now.
All right, I said Ghost
Maze, come on down
and make sure your
projector, if you're
going to use a
projector at all, works.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: What's that?
PROFESSOR 1: I still
didn't understand.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: No, just like 4,
you only need as many people
as you need to
present to come down.
STUDENT 1: So if you remember,
our game was Ghost Maze.
And we'll run you
through a quick refresher
of what the game
actually was first
so you remember what it is.
STUDENT 2: So here we have
our character in a maze.
You've just woken up and
you're in a dark maze.
All you have is your lantern.
And so your objective
is to explore the maze,
avoid ghosts, and drop beacons
to help you explore the maze.
And find a key, which will
then unlock and exit for you
get out the maze.
And so there are
different effects
that happened during the games,
such as your sanity starts
decreasing as the games goes on.
And then randomly, as you're
sanity starts getting lower
and lower, your movement
will get impaired randomly,
and the light will turn red
as you can see in this picture
here.
And then another
interaction that we
had was when you get
close enough to a ghost,
your sanity start
decreasing faster.
So the light turns
blue to let you
know that you're
too close to a ghost
and you need to get
away from that ghost.
STUDENT 1: So a few
things that went
right was that it was hard to
balance everyone's schedules,
but everyone was pretty
flexible in terms of what
features they were working on.
So people would adapt
to the features that
needed to be done at that time.
So flexibility was,
I think, something
that went more or less
well, in terms of working
on what needed to be worked on.
The second thing that went
right was user experience.
So we spent a lot of time
focusing on user experience,
and playing with the camera,
playing with shadows,
playing with the
player movement.
We spend a lot of time
putting in graphics and audio
so that it seemed a little
more realistic to put you
in the context that you were
in a dark maze and lost.
A few things that went wrong
is we started out using Flixel.
But it took us a few days
and we still couldn't get up
a dev environment reading.
So we decided to
switch over to Unity.
That was a pretty wise choice,
but we made it pretty late.
We found that collaborative
coding on Unity
was really hard.
Certain changes
to the main scene
would wouldn't merge well.
So also when we were working
on different branches,
and then tried to merge
it back into master scene,
people's changes were
lost or overwritten.
So we found that Unity
wasn't great in terms
of like having a big team
project where a lot of people
are coding at once.
And sometimes we just
re-applied changes
on to the master branch.
Something else was we all
had really busy schedules.
People were out of town.
In town, they could only work on
the project at certain points.
So I think something that helped
with that was at the beginning,
we did a pretty good job of
delegating tasks to people who
work on the project earlier.
But then later on
it, it was pretty
haphazard in terms of who
is available at one of time.
So maybe re-evaluating
priorities
as the project went on would've,
I think, really helpful.
STUDENT 2: So
lessons learned, we
spent a lot of time
working on user experience.
Because we had a 3-D
perspective game,
there was a lot of
thought that went
into how the light was
hitting the player, how
to get the shadows
to cast properly,
how the player knows that
the players in the maze.
And being able to move
around and understand
how your sanity is decreasing.
We spent a lot of
time testing that.
Working early and
quickly-- this was partly
hindered because we lost
at least four days of work
because we were trying
to get Flixel set up.
And then it just didn't work.
And we had to
switch to Unity, so
basically starting
over from scratch.
Working early and quickly
is super important
because we ended
up having to drop
quite a few features because we
didn't get enough done on time.
And we also learned that working
in 3-D is very, very hard.
We were originally going to do a
2-D game, and then thought, oh,
how hard would it be?
We have a 2-D game, but let's
just give it a 3-D perspective.
That was not a good idea.
Doing the textures
took a long time.
It ended up looking
really, really nice,
as you can see in the pictures.
But the time investment
was a huge investment
that we could have used to put
in some more complex mechanic
into our game.
And future improvements, team
communication and availability
is a huge one.
We, as Rachel said, we
had a task assignment
at the beginning.
But then due to
people's schedule,
we didn't really take
that into account
when we made the
initial task list.
So people ended up having to
pick up other people's tasks.
And it became very
hard to figure out
who was working on what.
And scheduling meetings
was near impossible.
Getting familiar with the game
engine-- using Unity at first
was very hard because we
weren't sure how scenes work.
And eventually we
figured out that if we
make most of the stuff
dynamically generated then
we can just worry
about the code,
and not have to worry about
all the user interface stuff
that Unity does.
And that would have made our
game develop a lot quicker.
And setting deadlines
was very important.
We had a lot of tasks laid out.
But we didn't set
strict deadlines
for when we wanted each
task to be assigned,
or when we wanted each
task to be finished.
And that would have
helped push along our game
and get some of them more
mechanics that we wanted in it.
STUDENT 1: Yeah,
I think something
that a little bit arose
was when we were going
to plan on doing our testing
session because we should have
set the internal deadlines to
match the testing sessions so
that we get as much
feedback as possible.
But that said, we
still got something out
of the testing sessions.
So that was good.
I think that's all we have.
STUDENT 2: Yeah, that's it.
STUDENT 1: So I don't know
if you guys have questions.
STUDENT 3: I'm from
team Hardcore Dragon.
And as a refresher,
I mean our game is
about being a hardcore dragon.
So to us, that meant razing
villages, being chased down
by knights and accumulating
a horde of gold
that you have to
protect from looters.
And we all were pretty
excited about this idea.
And that was probably the
best thing about the project,
as a whole, is it
was a fun idea.
Even when we got bogged down
with work from other classes,
or something emerged, or
didn't go through correctly,
or there's was a bug, and
we couldn't understand
what was happening, it was
still really fun to be like,
OK, I really need to
make this dragon set
this village on fire.
And I want to do this
because that's awesome.
And another thing that
worked is that we use Gitter,
which integrates with GitHub.
Whenever something is pushed,
it'll show up on to the right
and you can link to it.
And everybody who's on your
project is on the Gitter chat.
So it was easy to
keep track of who
was working at what time,
who was online at that time,
and who you could ask
for help to let you
debug whatever was going wrong.
Another thing that
helped was Trello
is actually really good tool.
The last project, I
personally used Google Docs.
But Trello is much easier
to look at something,
drag it while I'm
doing this right now,
adding yourself to
things, and breaking it
down to simpler task.
It's all very easy on Trello.
I mean, it's built for this.
So it made long-term goal
planning a lot easier.
And you could see
at this moment who
was supposed to be doing what.
Unfortunately, the idea was
also a downside to the project
because it was Hardcore Dragon.
I want to do so many
things with this idea.
When I blow fire
on this thing, I
want it to turn into
a crumbled building
and become a pile of flames,
and it'll be awesome.
That's not necessarily at
the top of the feature list,
obviously, because we
have other mechanics that
are more important than that.
But we kept coming up with
these little additions that
would make the game a
lot more cool or awesome,
but are hard to prioritize
and just way too much
to stack on top of the game.
So that was the downside.
And it was just hard to
control-- it was hard to scope
the game down to the five
minutes game we needed
to create for the project.
Gitter was good with
the [INAUDIBLE].
If everybody was on and
everybody used it all the time,
it would be ideal.
But since a lot of us are on the
go and working on other things,
in classes while people are
working, using something else
might have been better, like
g-chat or Facebook, something
you can access
from a smartphone,
or something more instantaneous.
We would just get-- if you
weren't on Gitter at the time,
it would send you a
notification being like,
you missed these messages.
Which is almost as delayed
a message as email.
So it was kind of pointless
other than the fact
that it was
integrated with GitHub
and you could see who was
online at the same time as you.
Another thing that
didn't work is
that meetings are really,
really hard to coordinate
with seven people.
And what ended up happening
was that we would all be like,
OK, so half of us are
free this day, six of us
are free this other time.
Let's meet then.
And then we wouldn't
decide a specific time
within the time
were free to meet.
And then by the time we noticed
this, ti would like that day.
And it was just hard to
coordinate everything
after it got to that point.
So for the future,
I believe we would
have to have a fully
dedicated scrum master.
And I really mean
fully dedicated,
not scrum master AKA
programmer on the side,
or scrum master who also gets
music done and play tests,
well it does play testing.
Everybody play tests, but a
fully dedicated scrum master
to make sure that
everybody's on tasks,
that the meetings
will get scheduled,
and that the tasks
are prioritized.
And if something falls through,
they're the person to talk to,
they're the person who's going
to make you stop freaking out
that this task took
like three times as long
as you've estimated it for.
We didn't have this one
person dedicated to that.
Everybody was like a jack
of all trades in our group.
So not having that
one person to talk to,
go to, made task
prioritization really fuzzy,
and made everything kind of
come together really late.
And it was hard to
hold people accountable
because there wasn't
that one person who
was on top of everybody.
Another thing we
had to do earlier
would be feature cutting.
Because if you don't cut
features definitively earlier,
you'll still have it lingering
on some people's minds.
Oh, I have to do this
so that in the future
we're going to maybe
use this feature.
But if you cut these
features early,
you limit the propensity to
have bugs, or stuff like that.
While it's unfortunate that
you have to cut features,
it's necessary.
So doing it earlier is
the best time to do it.
Another thing is,
like I said before,
a native messaging system.
Gitter was cute but didn't
actually work in the way
that we wanted it to work.
It wasn't instantaneous
between all members.
It's hard to find a messaging
system that everybody likes.
But I think something like
G-chat or Facebook messaging,
something instantaneous
like that that most people
use already should
be used as a group
so that everybody can
be on the same page
and have access to
the instant messaging.
Yeah, our game is there
if you want to play it.
Anybody have questions?
PROFESSOR 1: So if you were to
do the feature cutting early,
did you feel like you had
the information in order
to do that?
STUDENT 3: So there
was some stuff
that like after even
half the halfway point,
that we could've cut features.
But instead of
the halfway point,
we did like two days ago,
which is too late already.
So even earlier than that.
It doesn't have to be like
day one feature cutting.
Just at maybe points
throughout, be
like, now that I'm here, what
features look like they're not
going to get through.
And with a dedicated
scrum master,
who's like looking
through, looking at people
and how they're struggling
with certain tasks,
maybe people don't know exactly
what their pace is internally.
But from an outside
perspective, a scrum master
might be able to more accurately
help with estimates and stuff
like that.
So a dedicated
scrum master would
help with early feature
cutting as well, probably.
PROFESSOR 1: This is a
Unity project, right?
STUDENT 3: Yeah,
a Unity project.
Yeah, sorry.
We actually didn't
have that many problems
with merging because we had,
I think, at least one of us
was really experienced with
Unity, so that's was lucky,
I guess.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Thank you.
STUDENT 3: You're welcome.
STUDENT 4: So our team
is MIT Simulator 2014.
So our basic concept was
you play as a certain dean
of MIT you may all know.
And you're making
decisions that trade off
between the endowment, wealthy
donors, and student approval.
And the basic goal
of the game is
to try and survive as long as
possible, while shitty things
happen to the institute.
So what went right
in our project?
I think what went
right in our project
is we connected
with our audience.
A lot of MIT students know
what it's like to be at MIT,
and they know the
setting, they knew
the administrator We're
not really pointing at,
but we kind of are.
And so a lot of people connected
very well with our game.
And so they enjoyed it and were
able to understand it easily
in their own terms.
So the second thing that went
well is that humor works.
A lot of our things in our game
were like kind of unpolished,
and kind of like
slapped together.
But because we had taken
the time to make them funny
and make them
entertaining, people we're
OK with losing all their
money in one turn [INAUDIBLE].
Because, hey, the
description of it was funny.
And so the third thing that
well is that simple is OK.
We ended up having like
very few core mechanics.
But then because of
the setting that we had
and because people connected
well with our game,
I think people are
still able to get--
we think people were still
able to get enjoyment out
of the game because of those.
So now what went wrong?
So first, Hex Flixel,
AKA what do you mean it's
not on Stack Overflow?
So Hex Flixel, while it did
play well with version control
and I heard some horror stories
about Unity version control,
Hex Flixel played pretty
well with version control.
But if you ever
had an issue, you
were pretty much out of luck.
You could search on Google, and
you'd get like zero results.
Sometimes the official
documentation wouldn't even
turn up on a Google
search result.
So documentation was
a little bit lacking.
I think the second thing
that we could have improve on
is that paperwork
is not management.
I think in the
class in particular,
this isn't emphasized
enough, is that you
can do all these agile
development methods,
like you can have a sprint
task list and everything.
But unless if you actually
have people who are actively
taking charge and
managing a project,
I think stuff still
won't get done.
I think that's something
that could be improved
in the future in this class is
like spend less time worrying
about paperwork, spend
more time actually
like teaching about how to
handle personal situations.
Like what happens if
someone doesn't have time.
Or what happens if
somebody like does this?
And so learning those managerial
skills isn't a trivial task.
And I think in the
beginning, we underestimated
how much those issues would
be a roadblock to progress.
And then the third thing
that went wrong I guess
is that responsibility
is shared.
So even if somebody has
a role assigned to them,
we should all still
like take the time
to make sure that like everybody
is completing their role.
So just making sure that people
are checking other people,
to make sure tasks don't
fall between the cracks.
And so overall people
do like the idea
of playing as a
certain dean of MIT.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR 1: So what
would you do different?
Not necessarily things about
the Hex Flixel, [INAUDIBLE].
But when it comes
to your management,
managing stuff we talked
about, what would you
want to do different, or what
[INAUDIBLE] particular problems
that you had.
And you know you're going
to have a feature that you
need to have scrappings for?
STUDENT 4: I think one thing
that we would do differently
is like take project management
more as like a people problem
then like a paperwork problem.
Because I think
like we kind of just
assume that by filling
in the sprint tasks list
and by writing git
commit logs, we magically
work together as a team.
But I think in the future,
just taking a more active role
in insuring that people are
interacting with each other
and communicating.
PROFESSOR 1: How about if I'm
[INAUDIBLE] the responsibility
of sharing things,
like how would you
address that [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT 4: I think for the
responsibility being shared
thing, I guess this
was just in reference
to a few particular
instances where
like we had someone
who would claim
that they would do something.
And then because we
assumed oh, because they
claim that they would do
it, that it would get done.
But I think sometimes
we got too complacent
and then thought that it would
actually get done anyways.
But I feel in the future
maybe just sending out
a couple more emails,
just having people confirm
that they've finished things,
require that people send out
emails confirming when
they finish things,
so we know that this thing
didn't get submitted yet.
Oh, shoot class is in an
hour, or something like that.
So just like encouraging
people to either like
poke each other
more, and also to be
more responsible about like
when you submit something.
Or when you do
something important,
you email out to
everyone just to show
that you've done the work.
PROFESSOR 3: Would
email be primary means
of communicating
between the team
or was there face to face
meetings outside of class,
or [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT 4: So email was our
primary means of communicating.
We had one face to face
meeting outside of class.
And then there was
another one that
was supposed to be scheduled
over the long weekend,
but things happened.
One or two people were
gone for the weekend,
and then things fell apart.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]?
Thanks.
STUDENT 5: This Is our
game Build a Spaceship.
It looks like this.
You have your ship with
a set of components
of a bunch of components
that you can add to the ship.
You click and drag
them onto the ship.
And then you send
it out on a mission.
After you go out
on that mission,
you'll get a log
that looks like this.
All this text is really
small, so you can't see it.
But it says things like, you met
some bandits, you had a battle,
you won and earned
this much money.
Or you got hit by asteroids
and lost this much health.
And the point is that after
you design your space ship
and sent it out on
this mission, you'll
get all this
feedback telling you
how you ship did so that you
can then update your ship
and send it out again, and
hopefully make even more money.
The goal of the game is to
complete a series of missions
that we have in
the game currently,
and make as much money as
you can while doing it.
Of course given more
time, we would do things
like add more components,
upgrading your ship,
and other tweaks like that.
But this is the core
of the game right here.
So what went right on our game?
We made a prototype really
early, which was great.
That helped us all
get on the same page
and understand what
we're talking about when
we're talking about the game.
There's was point
before that where
we had all these cool
ideas from brainstorming,
and a vague idea, a
personal idea, really,
of what the game would be.
And that made it really
difficult to communicate.
So once we had that
down, everything just
became way easier.
We did a lot of UI testing.
Even before we were sure about
the game would specifically be,
we knew that was going to
involve adding components
to a ship.
And so we knew we could UI test
that and see how people manage
with different ways of adding
those kind of components,
or customizing their ship.
Hex Flixel, we found it really
simple to work with actually.
And whenever we needed
to add more screens
or make changes the
game, we all had
a pretty intuitive understanding
of how that would go.
That might also be an
artifact of coming over
from Phaser, which is
very similarly structured.
And on our team, we got
lucky because everybody
had coding experience.
And it made it a lot
easier because we were all
speaking the same language.
And so on a time constraint
project like this,
it meant that when we talked,
we were more efficient about it.
That's not to say that
there is a place for people
who don't have coding
experience on these teams.
It's just that when we only have
two weeks to get things done,
the speed was a huge help.
What went wrong was
communicating our progress
on the game.
We had a lot of problems
where we wouldn't
talk about what was that done.
We didn't know what
was even in the game
because somethings
weren't clear yet.
Like there was one
part where we didn't
know that we could
actually add components
to ship because somebody had
added that in but not actually
told us.
And the UI wasn't there yet
to actually make it clear.
We also run into problems
with heroic efforts
where the night before
something was due,
somebody would like to come
in and put in all this effort.
And we didn't know
what they were doing,
and we didn't know
what was getting
done because we just weren't
communicating about that.
A problem that's
related to this is
that we didn't assigned
tasks well or take ownership
of what we were doing, or assign
responsibility between people.
And so we ran into
problems where things just
wouldn't happen for a
long spurts of time.
And then we'd run
into the heroic effort
problem at the end where
we're all jumping in
to make things happen.
We also ran into problems
where sometimes people
didn't push commit
for an entire day
and we had no idea what
the state of the game
actually wa So what
we learned from this,
and what we would do
differently next time
is first we'd keep
track of our progress
and make sure that
it's contiguous,
whether it's using Trello,
or emails, or any other sort
of solution for it,
it would be really
important to make sure we all
know what the state game is,
and what's being worked on.
We should come up with standards
for how we're going to email
and meet.
We talked about this, and
said it would be a good idea,
but then we didn't
actually do it.
So it would be good to have a
schedule of when your team is
going to meet, how
they're going to email
and why they're going to email,
if it's a daily update of what
you're doing, or if it's
every time you push a commit.
And also coming up
with standards for how
you're going to Git.
Are you going to use feature
branches, and all these kind
of things, or are you going
to do it all on master?
And are you going to push every
time you make a new commit?
Or are we going to push
at a set time every day
so that we can track
it all at once?
If would be good to
know who's doing what.
That comes in with the idea
of communication and tracking
progress.
What we did at first was
we had specific domains
that people were working on.
Jeremy was working
on the UI, Rodrigo
was working on the ship model.
And this made it really
easy to assign tasks
and to make sure
that things were
getting done in the beginning.
But then in the end, when
we had some tasks that
were kind of in the middle
and we didn't specifically
say what was going to
happen, we ended up
with this last minute scramble
of, OK, I'll take this thing.
Actually I'll take this thing.
Somebody else is coming in.
And it made a lot more
difficult to track
what was actually getting done.
You can also give
tasks to people.
We were kind of reluctant
to do that at first.
But we got better and
it, and it was actually
super helpful to just be
like, hey, you take this.
And then it's completely
clear what happening.
And the very last
thing to do with this
is to just ask what's happening.
It's good to get some
reassurance that something
actually is happening if you're
not hearing anything about it.
So you can just ask someone.
Hey, what are you working on?
Or hey, is anybody working on
making this component up here?
Then you just get an answer.
And you get a lot of
peace of mind from that.
It's good to set up specific
times to work together.
We didn't do this enough, but it
would've been great if we had.
And like I said, we made a
prototype pretty early on.
But I think we could have
made one even earlier.
We found that it didn't limit
our creativity or our ability
to talk about the game.
Instead it just gave us a
platform to work off of.
So we could build
a basic prototype
with some idea of
a core mechanic,
and then continue to brainstorm
and expand from there.
And that's basically what
we learned from this game.
And moving forward,
we're looking forward
to implementing
this on project 4.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: The site's solving
problems with HaxeFlixel
all on your own, did you
find any online resources
that turned out to be helpful?
Or did you just [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT 5: The main problem
that we ran into with HaxeFlixel
was we were trying
to build an HTML5,
and the text just
wasn't working.
And we found nothing about it.
We found one page by
HaxeFlixel that said,
sometimes we have
problems with text.
Try doing this.
That didn't work.
And nobody else has
an answer for it.
I don't know if
anybody else did.
AUDIENCE: Basically you have to
read the Flixel documentation
and ignore the
HaxeFlixel documentation.
[INAUDIBLE] identical
and the static typing
does save you a little bit.
And you have to jump into
the source occasionally.
There's nothing wrong with that.
STUDENT 5: Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
STUDENT 6: So we did
Looking for Deena.
And we have some screenshots
of the games in case any of you
didn't get to play it or see it.
So it's just a search screen.
The first thing-- so the
game is kind of in two--
you have to do two
different things.
The first thing you do is you
choose which planet you're
going to go to.
And you can't really read it,
but they all different distance
stats as well as stat games
that each planet will give you.
Then you have to navigate
through an asteroid fields,
which depending on how far
along you are in the game,
makes it harder as you go along.
But hopefully you
have those stat games
that should make it easier
to actually go through it.
You're looking for Deena.
And you can lose and win.
So what was right
and what was wrong
is we did communicate a lot.
And by a lot, I mean from
midnight to like this class,
there's 108 emails.
And that was just today.
So we communicated a lot.
But we didn't communicate
really effectively.
There were a lot of
people saying like,
this what I'm doing,
this is what I'm doing,
this is what I'm
doing, this is done.
I submitted this.
But then going through those
hundreds of emails trying
to figure out, oh
wait, who said they
were doing this, who said this
was submitted, was really hard.
And so we didn't have
those daily scrum meetings
that we talked about.
And I'm realizing those would be
really useful to have somebody
say like,
OK, this is what
everybody's done.
This is what
everybody's going to do.
This is what we've submitted.
Having that one thing somewhere
where everyone can view it
easily would make
it a lot easier
than trying to go through email
and figuring out who did what
and what went wrong.
One other thing we did right
was we went in smaller group.
So people were working on the
design, just those people met.
And then people working on
the code, just those people
met, which was really
useful for trying to meet.
Instead of having
seven people meet,
you only had like three or four.
And so much easier to
arrange those meetings.
We really divided the
tasks effectively.
Everybody was doing something.
And that's what
the last point is.
Everybody tried to make
sure they were always
doing something and
contributing to the project.
No one was just sitting there
wondering, what do I do.
Everyone tried to constantly
be doing something.
Another thing that went wrong
is that we worked in bursts.
People were really busy.
And then the night before we
assigned an internal deadline,
everyone's was like, oh OK,
let's work on this right now.
And so then it was just
people staying up all night
to try to finish something.
Which things got done,
but sometimes it's like,
did we do this the
best way we could.
Was everything optimized?
And we weren't really
sure because everything
was done in short
bursts, instead of
like a little bit of every day.
And do you guys want
to talk about Unity?
STUDENT 7: Yeah.
As people have said, Unity is
annoying because it has all
these binary files
that you cannot merge.
So if two people were-- we had
to basically always keep track
of, I'm working on this scene.
No one else touch it.
Because if two
people work on it,
someone is going
to lose everything
in it, which is really annoying.
Emails worked for that.
And so that way you could say, I
finished working on this scene.
Someone else can touch it now.
So that was sort of helpful.
STUDENT 8: [INAUDIBLE]
spits up like five of them.
And you're like,
I think it's fine.
But sometimes a
conflict happens.
And you're like, I don't
know what to do with this.
I think I can check all of them.
But then things break
and you're [INAUDIBLE].
I feel like that scheme
is weird in the scene
because at least we tell each
other, stop touching the thing,
or touching the thing.
But something you touch the
thing and something else
happens entirely.
And you're like, OK.
STUDENT 7: I also
want to point out
how impossible it is to schedule
anything for seven people.
We wanted to meet
on the weekend.
And there was literally
not a single period
of time, not one hour that
wasn't at 3:00 of 4:00
in the morning where
everyone was asleep.
It was impossible.
It was insane.
STUDENT 6: Yeah,
schedules are hard.
STUDENT 8: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 6: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: You have two points
about [INAUDIBLE] items up
that appear to [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 6: So we did
keep to deadlines.
So what I was trying
to say with that point
is that we did kind of
keep the deadlines where
we worked in those bursts
to get to the deadline.
But then because it was such a
long burst, by the end everyone
was drained.
And if it was
like, I'll do this,
and this other
little small thing,
a lot of little small
things didn't get done.
And so things were kind
of push back a little bit.
And so this led to more bursts.
And it was a really
bad cycle that I
think ended up happening.
AUDIENCE: Do you think if
you planned for the bursts,
it would be better?
If you actually scheduled
meetings at 3:00 before?
STUDENT 7: So I think
we need more granularity
in the deadlines.
So we'd say, let's
get this bucket
of things done by this day.
And that would--
people procrastinate.
We have other work to do.
Well, I have this other
deadline for this other class
is due first, and leave
everything for this till later,
until you're finished
with every other class.
So if you leave smaller
tasks, more spread out
throughout the week, I think
that would enforce a more,
I'll work a little bit today
and a little bit tomorrow,
as opposed to I'll work a whole
time two days from today, which
is what ended up happening.
STUDENT 9: We also didn't have
that [INAUDIBLE] scrum master
or project manager who would
reinforce those deadlines
[INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 6: Yeah, you
would just get an email
saying I have something
due at midnight.
I'll start working on
this after midnight.
So a lot of times that would
happen, and things like got
pushed back because that
person didn't get that done.
And so you kind of have to wait.
STUDENT 7: But I
think we got it done.
STUDENT 6: But
everything got done.
STUDENT 8: It's very cute.
I feel like that's
what [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 2: [INAUDIBLE]
you can [INAUDIBLE] a lot
if it wasn't well organized.
Do you have any thoughts
on how you might better
organize your communications
on the project?
How do still have that good
level of communication,
but have it be
something [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT 7: So I think
a big problem we had is
we had just one
enormous email thread,
which became huge and monolithic
and impossible to look through
after a certain point.
I think it would have
more helpful to break up
into smaller email threads.
So like people that were working
on a specific feature in code,
not everyone needs to
receive all those emails.
So it would have been, I think,
really helpful for the future
to maybe organize it in the
send that if me and Jenny are
working on something, we
email each other a lot.
And at the end of the
day, we send one email.
Here are the details that
everyone needs to know.
You don't need to
receive the 10,000
emails we sent before that.
So I have to say, keep
everyone in the loop.
Don't leave people
out of the loop.
But keep little pockets
of communication
so everyone's not flooded
with all this stuff.
STUDENT 6: And even having
the designated scrum master,
I think, would help
with that a lot.
Because then it's not
even they're sending it
out to the group email thread.
They're sending it to the scrum
master and the scrum master
makes one thing.
It would be really tiresome
to do that every day though.
So maybe every other
day or something.
I'm not really sure
how to break that up.
Because it seems
like you'll just
end up having a lot of
things, like a lot of reports.
Report this was done this day,
this was done on this day.
PROFESSOR 2: Did you
[INAUDIBLE] place to track where
what tasks were
done [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT 6: We had the Google
Doc with the change log.
PROFESSOR 2: You
did the change log.
But were people updating,
changing, task lists
or anything like that?
STUDENT 7: I think
that was mostly done in
like-- so we'd say, these are
the sets of tasks that we want
to finish today, or something.
And then I, for example,
I'm going to work on this.
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to work on this scene.
No one touch it.
OK, I'm done working
on the scene.
And then once everyone finished
working on all the scenes,
then we'd go back [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 8: It does
feel like we probably
could have done some weird joint
thing where the sprint tasks
list keep track
of bigger things.
And then we have some kind
of chat email system going
on where we should
stay in contact,
especially with [INAUDIBLE].
At the same time, it's
a little bit like , hm,
what level of tasks, size,
goes into the sprint task list?
Because [INAUDIBLE] something
really small, it's like yeah,
this is what we spent
the last two hours doing.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 8: [INAUDIBLE]
task [INAUDIBLE] is hard.
AUDIENCE: But what
really [INAUDIBLE].
That's what, if
you can figure out
a way to have something
[INAUDIBLE], whether it's just
a list [INAUDIBLE] where you can
say, hey, I finished this task,
can sum it up [INAUDIBLE]
task was based on that.
Or if you can go to [INAUDIBLE]
troubleshooting or something.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STUDENT 10: Hi.
So I'm going to be
talking about Score High.
This is actually
our start screen.
So just in case you don't
remember what Score High is,
it was a game where you
played as an MIT student.
You went around to
different buildings,
did your homework assignments,
ate, slept, and basically
just tried to survive school.
So I'm going to start off by
talking about what went poorly.
And the first thing we had
an issue with was direction.
So this time, we didn't
have a paper prototype.
We had an idea that
we wanted to do.
But it ended up changing a
lot right from the start.
And it became really
difficult to stay on topic
because we didn't really
know what we were doing.
And very much related to that,
we then had issues with scope.
We started off with a
lot of unrelated features
and a lot of components.
And even now in our final game,
there are a lot of components
and the way they interact
is complicated sometimes.
And then finally, I think every
single team has mentioned this,
just planning ahead, and
getting work done earlier,
and planning time to work
together-- the issues we had
especially that came up
later were a lot of issues
with midterms,
things going wrong,
everything that could go
wrong kind of went wrong.
And if we had
started earlier, we
wouldn't have
had-- we would have
been able to deal with
those situations better.
So based on that, what was well?
Well, the great
thing is that we did
start right away just setting
up everything we needed to work.
We set up our email thread,
our Google Drive folder.
We decided on Unity
first meeting,
and we set up the GitHub
project right away so
that we could all collaborate.
And the nice thing was
in our Google Drive
folder we put our task list.
We really utilized that.
And our email thread,
like other teams said,
it did get a little
long and complex.
But it was just so nice to have.
And later on, we actually
also got a group text
messaging service.
So that works really well
dealing with that last minute
hustle kind of stuff.
The next thing I
went really well
is I told you that our
scope was way out there.
We realized that very
quickly, and we just
started cutting,
cutting, cutting.
So we cut items.
We cut interactive
AI characters.
We cut playable quizzes.
We just cut everything
that wasn't key.
Because our game, even
without all the things,
already had a lot of components.
And then once we have a playable
game, the next thing we did
was we looked into feedback.
So one of the main feedbacks
we got was our game
was not visually cohesive.
It did not make sense.
The nice thing
about Score High was
that because you're
playing as an MIT student,
you're just getting work done,
people understood how to play
and what they were
supposed to do.
But they didn't understand that.
So if you look at the
thing on the left,
you're probably all just staring
at it being like, what's that.
The rectangles are
buildings, and the bottom's
the stats bar, on the
right is the schedule.
It's confusing.
People didn't notice
the stat bars,
or they thought
they were buildings,
and things like that.
So we responded to
that right away.
And we said, we need
to clarify this.
We need to separate the
status, separate the schedule,
and make the map very clear, and
pretty, and easy to get around.
So that was one thing
we responded to,
and I think it went well.
The next thing that we
responded to feedback
was we really listened to
players, not only big picture,
but on smaller things.
Players wanted WASD,
so we put WASD.
They wanted a clear
way to leave buildings.
They wanted to know
what was going on when
they were in a building.
So we actually inserted
a progress bar that says,
what's going on this building,
how it's affecting you.
And then to leave,
instead of pressing
space bar, which people
found unintuitive,
they press a button that says
leave-- much more intuitive.
Now given all that, we did
make a really good game.
But there are
definitely some things
we would change if we
were to do it again.
As I mentioned before, start
with something simpler.
We did not design the
game around the scope
of the project.
And if we were to do this
again, we definitely would.
We tried to bite off
more than we could chew.
And related to that, minimize
the number of components
and understand how
they will interact.
Because especially if you're
trying to break down tasks,
people need to
know what has to be
conveyed between
different components.
Plan for the worst.
Midterms suck.
People get sick,
or go out of town.
And laptops break.
Literally all of these
things happened to us.
We're still waiting to
hear, is the laptop working.
We don't know.
Somebody's laptop
broke last night
and they were working on
something and finishing it up.
And suddenly all
that work's gone.
So as I said, start
earlier, plan for the worst,
and just get things done.
Finally, it worked
out really well.
And thanks for listening.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: This was Unity?
STUDENT 10: Yeah, Unity.
I'm going to take
that as no questions.
PROFESSOR 1: Great.
Thank you.
STUDENT 10: Beautiful.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you so much.
And actually round of
applause for everyone here.
You actually did a
really great job.
I think we're going to give
you more detailed feedback
in a few days.
But I think one thing
we heard definitely
is by working in
these large teams,
you're coming
across these issues
that you don't initially-- you
still need tools to get over
some of the management
issues you're finding out,
the communication
issues you having,
the scheduling
issues you're having.
Part of this is just experience.
That's kind of why we just
throw you in the deep end,
is just to figure out
what are all the problems.
So that we could then
talk about and have
some common things
to talk, how we're
going to solve those things.
Looking at the schedule,
we'll probably end up
moving a couple things earlier.
Did you have a comment?
PROFESSOR 2: I just wanted
to make one comment.
It's possible your
groups might be slightly
larger for the next project.
I know.
But you've got a lot
more time because you've
got seven to eight weeks.
And what I really
want to encourage
you guys to do is if you realize
you're having communication
and organization
problems with your group,
if you're not sure how
to organize things,
or if it's not working, stop
by the office and talk to us.
I don't think we said
this clearly enough
in the previous projects.
But yes, our goal is, in
fact, to throw you out
into the deep end.
But we're not trying to
throw you out in the deep end
without at least a
floaty to hold onto,
or a safety rope or something.
We are happy to
sit down and talk
with you, a small
member of your group,
or your whole group
about how to come up
with some
individualized solutions
to your team's communication
and organizational problems.
OK?
PROFESSOR 3: That's
just a reminder,
if you don't know
where our office is,
it's in the syllabus.
It's in building 26
on the ground floor.
You can see our rooms all have
the MIT Game, that logo on it.
And what Rick was
saying about tools,
not all our tools are
like mechanical tools.
Not all our tools
are like are things
that you put in a spreadsheet.
The things like the meetings
that we've been talking about,
where you are actually
supposed to talk to each other.
It's important to actually
talk to each other
during those meetings,
for instance.
Of course, if you
don't have a way
to be able to schedule
those meetings because it's
hard to get people
together, you need
to find a replacement to be
able to have those opportunity
to talk with each other.
You can't just say,
well, we don't have time
to do this thing, therefore
we're not going to do it.
However, this being
the final project,
you're going to have
a lot of flexibility
to try out different ways to
communicate with your team.
So what worked in
your previous projects
should give you a good basis on
what you can do in the future,
but may not necessarily
work with your future team
because it might be
different groups of people.
And learn from the
previous three projects
about what worked.
Try it out.
And that doesn't work,
try something different.
You have time this time around.
Although still, eight weeks goes
by really, really, really fast.
So don't over scope.
PROFESSOR 1: So we
actually are running
really short on time today.
We've got a really
long-- a lot of content
that Pablo was going
to go over with us.
So let's take a
five minute break.
I'm actually going to skip
the project 4 introduction.
And I'll put the
slides up on Stellar.
And I'll give that
on Monday morning.
It's really just me
saying out loud what all
the-- Monday class.
Don't take everything
I say literally.
It's the spirit.
Monday at 1 o'clock.
So the slides will be up.
I'm really just going
over what it actually
says in the schedule
by saying it out loud.
So you can hear it and see it.
But we'll do that on Monday.
So take a break right now.
And I'm going to
get Pablo set up.
You can see some folks, Pablo?
PROFESSOR 4: I can
in the distance, yes.
Hello, everyone.
PROFESSOR 1: So let me
crank up the volume.
All right. the room is yours.
PROFESSOR 4: All right.
PROFESSOR 1: Whoa, loud.
PROFESSOR 4: Thank you
again to all of you
for still being there.
Thank to the team in
charge of the [INAUDIBLE]
for persevering with the
invitation on the guidance
of how to use this time.
I'm sure you, or at
least some of you,
should remember the slide
that I hope is on the screen.
There is a comfort zone
where people feel safe.
And most often, where people
are safe, not enough happens.
And one of the things--
one of the reason why
I hope we can work
together is to see
if we can create true games.
The magic circles that are
slightly outside of the comfort
zone of people will be a Red
Cross volunteer, a Red Cross
staff, a person
who is a scholar,
a donor, a government
official to try
to make something new happen.
And that something new
can be just understanding.
It can be about dialogue.
It can be about perceptions,
or it can be about some
of the ingredients that
eventually lead to action.
So now let's see if
this thing changes.
Did you see a change in slide?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR 4: Good.
So let me move this thing.
We're going to start
by playing [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to invite
everyone to stand up.
And Reid, can I ask you and
someone to partner up with you
to be in a place
where I can see you.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: Maybe Sarah,
or whoever you choose.
PROFESSOR 3: I'll do it.
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Where
are we in the camera?
Hey, there we are.
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: Stand.
PROFESSOR 4: So everybody
find-- yeah, right.
When I say stand up, I mean it.
So everybody find a partner,
shake hands with your partner.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, no.
Cutting out.
PROFESSOR 4: What you're going
to do now is each one with two
in the duo is going
to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: Oh,
you've dropped out.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh no.
PROFESSOR 3: How's the network?
PROFESSOR 4: Uh oh.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, we're getting
a little bit of network drops
here.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, may I
suggest the following then.
If it is a matter of bandwidth,
you can stop your video
and that should work.
PROFESSOR 1: We'll do that.
PROFESSOR 4: You'll be in
charge of through audio
making sure I know--
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah,
it dropped again.
PROFESSOR 4: But you're still
there and kind of following.
OK, can you hear me now?
PROFESSOR 1: We can hear you.
PROFESSOR 4: So
each one of you is
going to hold an
imaginary deck of cards.
Cards are number 1 to 10.
And I want you to shuffle
these imaginary cards.
I want you to take the
top half of the deck
and swap it with your partner.
And then you shuffle again,
those imaginary cards.
So you should have a lot
of imaginary cards numbered
1 to 10 in random order.
If you're thinking, what does
this have to do with Red Cross,
we'll get there.
So now, this is crucial.
Each one of you is going to
take the top imaginary card,
make some body movement
to reveal the moment when
you're flipping it.
And [INAUDIBLE] state that the
number that is on the top card.
For example, [INAUDIBLE]
as well so say your number
at the same time.
PROFESSOR 3: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 6.
Oh hey, you don't
have 10 fingers.
PROFESSOR 4: Let's try it
again using body language
to make sure it's simultaneous.
PROFESSOR 3: 1, 2, 3--
PROFESSOR 1: 10.
PROFESSOR 3: 5.
5.
PROFESSOR 4: All right.
So I couldn't hear the
number, but first of all, you
don't need to say 1, 2, 3.
You can use body language to
make it happen simultaneously.
It's to your advantage to
make it as fast as possible.
Two things can happen.
If the two players
say different numbers,
there's no consequence and you
try again a different number--
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, no.
The video is slowing down.
PROFESSOR 4: or the same
number, whichever you want,
any-- [INAUDIBLE].
OK, it's the audio [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, the
audio is cutting out.
And the video is pausing.
Do you want to just switch back
to me controlling the slides
and you on audio only?
PROFESSOR 4: Sure.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, let's do that.
PROFESSOR 3: I think he
can just turn off his--
PROFESSOR 1: So
yeah, if you just
go ahead and turn
off your video,
and I'll make sure
I have slides.
PROFESSOR 4: All right, yes.
Let me get back to this.
How do I do it?
There.
PROFESSOR 1: Cool.
Let me go back to this.
PROFESSOR 4: So is
the audio now better?
PROFESSOR 1: So far, yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, good.
So what I was going to say is
that the two players are going
to say numbers simultaneously.
If the two numbers stated
simultaneously are different,
you keep going.
You keep saying numbers
at the same time.
But if the two players say the
same number at the same time,
the first player to say "snap"
takes all the imaginary cards
and wins one imaginary point.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: You keep going, OK?
And you start again.
The purpose is in
one minute or less
to snap as much as you can.
Those are the rules.
Shuffle your cards.
Ready, set and go.
You have less than a minute.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 6.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 10.
PROFESSOR 3: 7.
PROFESSOR 1: 8.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 9.
PROFESSOR 1: 2.
PROFESSOR 3: 12.
PROFESSOR 1: 1
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 6.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 8.
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 10.
PROFESSOR 3: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 3: 5.
PROFESSOR 1: 6.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap!
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
OK, you got the point.
1.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 6.
PROFESSOR 1: 6
PROFESSOR 3: 2
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 1.
PROFESSOR 1: 7
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 8
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 8.
PROFESSOR 3: 8, snap!
PROFESSOR 1: Ah,
OK, you get a point.
PROFESSOR 3: All right.
PROFESSOR 1: 9.
PROFESSOR 3: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 10.
PROFESSOR 3: 3
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 3: 8.
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 6.
PROFESSOR 1: 6.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 1.
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 5.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap!
PROFESSOR 3: Snap!
All right, I think you got it.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 3: All right.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 8.
PROFESSOR 3: 8.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap!
PROFESSOR 3: Ah, OK.
You got two points.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 3: All
right, is that good?
Or go again?
OK.
PROFESSOR 1: [INAUDIBLE].
5.
PROFESSOR 3: 5
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 8.
PROFESSOR 3: 9.
PROFESSOR 1: 10.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 6.
PROFESSOR 1: 2.
PROFESSOR 3: 12.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: 1.
PROFESSOR 3: 8.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 9.
PROFESSOR 1: 4.
PROFESSOR 3: 10
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 4.
PROFESSOR 1: 2.
PROFESSOR 3: 5.
PROFESSOR 1: 5.
PROFESSOR 3: 6
PROFESSOR 1: 7.
PROFESSOR 3: 8.
PROFESSOR 1: 9.
PROFESSOR 3: 2.
PROFESSOR 1: 3.
PROFESSOR 3: 3.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap!
PROFESSOR 3: Ah.
OK, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: So I have four?
PROFESSOR 3: I
think that you win.
I think you just win this game.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: Are you talking?
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: OK,
I can't hear you.
Should I shut them up?
PROFESSOR 4: Yes, please.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
All right, can we hear you?
PROFESSOR 4: Well,
I was actually
trying to be heard for
the past 30 seconds.
OK, so what we're going to
do now-- can you hear me?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
PROFESSOR 4: Good.
What you are going to
do now is to find--
we are going to play a
second round with two
minor differences.
The first minor difference--
don't do it yet.
But you have to shake hands
with a different person.
You will find a new partner.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: The
second difference
is that instead of having
numbers 1 through 10,
you are going to have
the names of animals.
AUDIENCE: What?
AUDIENCE: Holy crap.
PROFESSOR 4: Each
one of you should
know more than 10 animals.
So it shouldn't be a problem.
Find your partner.
Shake hands.
PROFESSOR 3: Someone else?
PROFESSOR 4: Shuffle your deck.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Oh.
PROFESSOR 4: And I--
PROFESSOR 3: OK, you guys play.
PROFESSOR 4: --request you
stop it in 30 seconds or less.
PROFESSOR 3: We're suppose
to do somebody else, right?
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: So let's
do anybody else.
How about I play with you.
You play Rick.
PROFESSOR 1: Go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: All
it's 30 seconds.
OK, all right,
back to the screen.
OK.
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
PROFESSOR 1: All right,
Pablo, you're back.
PROFESSOR 3: This was harder.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: So clearly
I'm not in the room.
Can you hear me guys?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: Good.
Even though I'm
not in the room, I
imagine that what
usually happens
may have happened again here.
First of all, it seems
much harder to snap.
Second, more people find
themselves going, ah, and not
saying an animal.
There was like clogging
of the brain cells.
And then very
interestingly, very often
people don't listen
to each other.
So for example, the first
time I played, I was saying,
dog, cat, mouse, and
my partner was saying,
zebra, giraffe, lion.
And it took us a
long time to notice
that we were in
different universes,
that we were never
going to snap.
And then interestingly, when
you finally say the same words,
a lot of people don't snap.
Their brain cells do not
get in the right place.
So when you play
the next round, I
want you to go back to
your original partner.
And in your deck of
cards, you are not
going to have
numbers 1 through 10.
You are not going
to have animals.
You are going to have
words or concepts that you
associate with the Red Cross.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 4: Whatever you want--
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: --it has to be
short, three words or less.
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: And of course,
you're trying to snap.
So you have 10
seconds [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: OK, all right.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: OK, sure.
PROFESSOR 4: On your
marks, ready, set, go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 3: You
want to try this?
STUDENT 11: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
One--
STUDENT 11: I don't know
anything about Red Cross.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
Health.
STUDENT 11: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: [INAUDIBLE].
Red.
PROFESSOR 3: Beds.
STUDENT 11: People.
PROFESSOR 3: People Oh, snap.
STUDENT 11: Snap.
You got it.
PROFESSOR 1: All right,
back to the screen.
PROFESSOR 3: OK, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: All right,
back to you, Pablo.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, thank you all.
If what usually happens
in this game happened
in the room, first of all, it's
even more difficult for people
to come up with words.
It's even more difficult
to snap And much more
than before, people
are realizing
in the process of trying to
play this game, that they don't
really know what they think
about the subject matter
we proposed in the
third round of the game.
So what I'm going to
invite you to do now
is very quickly form
groups of three.
Don't start yet.
Let me finish explain.
Form groups of three.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, no.
Your audio just cut out
and the video just cut out.
Are you back?
PROFESSOR 4: I cannot hear.
PROFESSOR 1: Can
you hear us now?
PROFESSOR 4: OK, now I can hear.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, yeah, the
audio just cut out briefly.
But you're back again.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, good.
Now I'm back with
audio and video?
PROFESSOR 1: You're
back with audio.
I don't see the video.
But I've got the slide up.
PROFESSOR 4: So let me
take video out of there.
So what we are going to do
now, if you can hear me--
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
PROFESSOR 4: --is to form
groups of about three people,
[INAUDIBLE].
And you're going to, as
a trio, write four terms,
four things that you
would have wanted to write
in that last deck of cards.
Is that clear?
So it's not about numbers.
It's not about animals.
It's about words
that are constantly
associated with the Red Cross.
Form a trio and write
four things that you hope
would be in the deck of cards
so you can try to snap Go.
You have three minutes.
PROFESSOR 3: Oh, OK.
Everyone, gets four cards.
PROFESSOR 1: Actually, you
can just use scrap paper too.
This is just in case
you don't have any.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 3: Do you
have enough cards?
I've got a lot.
I've got another deck here.
Do you need some more cards?
There's a pile here.
STUDENT 12: Thank you.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, there you go.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 3: Extras?
Everyone has four, right?
Oh, groups of three.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 3: I gave
you a few extra
just in case you make a mistake.
PROFESSOR 4: Rick,
can you hear me?
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah,
I can hear you.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, so I
want you to give them
no more than 30 seconds left.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: And let them
know that time is running out.
PROFESSOR 1: All
right, 30 seconds left.
PROFESSOR 4: And then, Rick,
what [INAUDIBLE] going?
PROFESSOR 1: The slide
is showing, yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: Sorry?
PROFESSOR 1: The slide?
PROFESSOR 4: No.
Well, yeah, actually,
[INAUDIBLE], no slide yet.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: It's easier
if you just do it.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: What I want you
to do is to pick some trio,
ask the trio to choose one
of the words [INAUDIBLE]
they have on their cards and
invite all the other groups
to say "snap" if they
wrote that exact term.
PROFESSOR 1: OK,
did we get that?
So one trio come up and
give one of your terms.
Just stand up and
start over here.
So what's one of your terms?
AUDIENCE: Disaster relief.
PROFESSOR 1: Disaster relief?
Snap, snap.
How many?
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap.
Three.
So we had four or five.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, now
choose another trio.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, another one.
PROFESSOR 4: Another trio
to say one of your words.
PROFESSOR 1: All right, term?
AUDIENCE: Red.
AUDIENCE: Snap.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Red
PROFESSOR 1: What was the word?
AUDIENCE: Red.
PROFESSOR 1: Red?
All right.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, so do the
same with a few more trios,
maybe three or four more trios.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
AUDIENCE: Blood donations.
PROFESSOR 1: What's that?
PROFESSOR 1: Blood donations.
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap, snap.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap, snap, snap.
OK, another trio.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Aid.
PROFESSOR 1: Aid?
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 1: Snap, snap, snap.
All right, another one.
AUDIENCE: CPR.
PROFESSOR 1: CPR?
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
PROFESSOR 1: No CPR?
PROFESSOR 4: Interesting.
No snapping with that one, huh?
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: OK.
So there are two reason
why I wanted to do this.
Thank you all very much.
If we had the time, we
would play this game
in a version that has
winners and losers, where
we would eliminate the
most and the least snaps.
And the second most
and second least snaps
are the winners, for example.
So you have to choose which of
your cards to say, and so on.
There are two reasons why I
wanted to share this with you.
One is to re-energize the
room and bring it back
into the game zone.
And the second one-- it's the
flavor of one of the games
that I hope maybe some
you will consider doing.
When we play this game in
the context of [INAUDIBLE],
for example, we
play [INAUDIBLE],
first with numbers,
then with animals,
and then we with the subject
matter of the course, which
can be climate change.
It can be humanitarian, law.
It can be [INAUDIBLE].
It can be shelter.
It can be urban risk.
And people come up with words.
And they write them down.
And we keep those papers.
And then after [INAUDIBLE],
which can be an hour, or a day,
or a week, we [INAUDIBLE].
And we ask them to
form different trios
and to write the words
that they [INAUDIBLE].
And that collection
allows us to compare
the before and the after on
how the thinking changed.
[INAUDIBLE], did you
show the slide that
has the two printouts?
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, I got that.
PROFESSOR 4: So [INAUDIBLE]
and change this here.
This is where we
played about insurance.
The one on the left
was the before.
And you see [INAUDIBLE] and
[INAUDIBLE], premium, accident,
disaster.
When we played the
game afterwards,
there were more nuanced terms.
There was [INAUDIBLE] collected.
There was buffered.
There was future.
There was return.
There was long term.
And this was very
difficult for us
to see how the thinking changed
as a result of the session.
So moving on to the next slide
that says choices for your game
project, these are
the six choices
that I want to make
available to you.
The zero one is to
create a digital version
of the game that could be played
along the lines of what you
just did, but for us an
accelerated collection of data,
so that everyone can see at the
same time what just happened.
I'll explain it more later.
Then in the list,
you see UNICEF Ghana.
And this is about cholera,
a waterborne disease
that is very tough.
And invite two groups if
possible to take this one,
because it's an
important one to us.
And it's about helping
schoolchildren in West Africa
to manage health risks.
The next one is about linking
early warning forecasts
with early action, decisions
that can help save lives.
Since it is 75 in Boston
or Cambridge today,
we thought it would be
relevant to say that we
wanted to focus on heat waves.
We could make it
about hurricanes.
We could make it about
volcanic eruptions.
We could make it
about many things.
But we invite heat waves,
because there are a few reasons
that make it useful to us.
The next one is perhaps the most
challenging one intellectually.
It's about new
funding mechanisms
for disaster preparedness.
I will explain this.
We call it forecast-based
financing, or FBF.
And it's the one that has the
most potential to transform
the humanitarian world.
The fourth one is Ebola.
As you can imagine, this
is a very challenging time
for my colleagues.
And maybe some of
you can give a hand.
And the last one involves
adaptation to climate change.
I think you may have met
[INAUDIBLE], my partner.
He designed [INAUDIBLE]
project for an organization
called Plan International,
focused on work with children
[INAUDIBLE].
So moving on to the
next slide, before we
go into the details of each
one of those potential topics,
I wanted to show
you some thoughts
about why digital
games for these things.
As you remember, hopefully,
from the previous visit to MIT,
the vast majority of our
games have been non-digital.
We've played them face to face.
They have been very good for
what thew were intended to do.
But they were reaching a very
small group of people, only
those who were here.
Recently, we designed--
or recently collaborated
in the design of our
first digital game that
was to be used in a
MOOC with [INAUDIBLE].
And it reached 35,000
people, which I'm pretty sure
has doubled the
number of people that,
since the beginning
of my work with games,
have been playing games
that are non-digital.
There's clearly [INAUDIBLE]
to many, many people.
And we're thinking of Red Cross
staff, colleagues of mine who
have a job, because this is
their managers, [INAUDIBLE],
whatever it may be.
There's also Red
Cross volunteers,
people who are not paid
[INAUDIBLE] some work.
It could be digital
games that people
at risk, people who
would make some decisions
to save their lives or save
the lives of their neighbors.
It could be about youth
and the schoolchildren,
who maybe don't know something
could learn through a game,
or had a [INAUDIBLE] that could
inspire through digital games.
And there's also the bigger
interpretations, especially
now in a time where
there's crowd funding,
there is people who
have the ability
to act in [INAUDIBLE]
number of little things
and make them bigger.
[INAUDIBLE] is that
games, including
digital games and [INAUDIBLE]
of the many ingredients
needed to support
a bigger change.
We are not widely optimistic.
It's not that we believe
that someone lives
their life in a
certain way, and then
they play a game, and boom,
they're a different person,
and they change their behavior.
Maybe that can happen.
But we are aware that it
takes more than a simple game
to play to change minds.
But we believe that games
can help invite people
to change behavior [INAUDIBLE].
It can be about
creating awareness.
engaging their desire,
their want to learn more.
It can be about a way give
them interest, the appetite.
Or it can be about
inspiring people
to take something that
[INAUDIBLE] they already do
and put it into
motion, [INAUDIBLE].
Importantly, because of
[INAUDIBLE]-- sorry--
last bullet.
There's so much hope
in digital technology,
in people who can
program, in people
who have cell phones
and [INAUDIBLE] Africa.
And we see a lot
of room for growth
within our team designing
and deploying digital games,
particularly with
UNICEF, but also
with many examples of
organizations [INAUDIBLE].
So moving on, I should
probably come to the next one.
Rick, would you like to either
inject anything or invite
questions at this
stage before moving
to the details of each game?
PROFESSOR 1: Sure.
So yeah, are there questions
about the target audience
or the reasons for digital
games before we move on?
Yeah, one question?
AUDIENCE: Will we
be able to play test
with our target audience?
PROFESSOR 1: So play testing
with the target audience--
are any of these folks
in the Boston area
that we could invite in
for a play test session?
PROFESSOR 4: Almost
certainly not.
So what we can do is to
play the games with people
who are as close as we can get.
So you know, schoolchildren
[INAUDIBLE], most of them
are different from
children in West Africa.
But I imagine that [INAUDIBLE].
There are a lot [INAUDIBLE]
prototype for Ghana
if you play it with children
in Cambridge or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: Having said that,
I may be able to get colleagues
in developing countries
to download your code
and play in [INAUDIBLE].
So [INAUDIBLE] on the
possibility for play
test with the target audience.
But it is in the
nature of this work
to work for the benefit
of developing countries.
So we'll have to
accept that there
is going to be a limited
ability to play test.
And that's something that can
happen in the early phases
of the project design.
Basically, we could
do it if you had
the budget for a planet ticket.
And it might be hard.
PROFESSOR 1: Was there
another question I saw?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you
envisioning this
being used as a one
on one thing, where
one person is playing the game?
Or are you
envisioning this being
used as sort of an
alternative to a presentation,
similar to the games
that we've seen here.
PROFESSOR 4: Yeah, it
depends on the game.
Generally speaking, mostly
because of the [INAUDIBLE]
in your ability to spend
student time on both the games,
we are sticking to ideas that
can be implemented for one
player with one computer or
one device, [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: --which
can happen in the house,
happen in the street when
they're waiting for the bus.
Or it can happen in a group, in
the context of a [INAUDIBLE].
But we decided to [INAUDIBLE]
multiplayer variable
for more sophisticated
endeavors.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
So yeah, when I talk further
about the constraints
on Monday, I'll be
mentioning that you
could do a single player
or multiplayer game.
But it will be a single
device, no networking.
And we are asking you to think
about the spectator experience.
So what does it look like to
be looking over the shoulder?
What does it look like to be
looking down on the table,
if it's an iPad game
or a tablet game?
What does it like if
somebody's playing
the game on a screen like this?
Consider one of those.
And design it
towards one of those.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So by schoolchildren,
is this elementary, middle,
or high school?
And also, can we assume
they speak English?
PROFESSOR 1: So
for schoolchildren,
is there a particular age range,
elementary, middle, or high?
And is there an English
language assumption going on?
PROFESSOR 4: Yes.
So yes to English.
And it will be [INAUDIBLE]
official language
is [INAUDIBLE].
So children go to school
and learn at some age.
And different products
have different age ranges.
But generally speaking,
it's roughly the ones
that are schoolchildren
are not [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll get to that in
the details for each game.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
PROFESSOR 4: So
moving on, if you
want to press the slide
for the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: Thumbs up.
PROFESSOR 4: Those
of you who were
at the game's
initial [INAUDIBLE]
may remember the game where
you all standing, and there
was a die, [INAUDIBLE].
And if there was a 6, you
had to do the umbrella.
Otherwise, you had
to do thumbs up.
Or if you push again,
[INAUDIBLE] sitting [INAUDIBLE]
on the cement, and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
PROFESSOR 4: Those are the
two basic [INAUDIBLE] that we
generally remember things.
You either do the usual,
or do something new.
And what we want
is to [INAUDIBLE]
a player the idea that you
can't make wrong decisions
without negative consequences.
But it's really hard to
know whether the decision is
the right one or the wrong
one before the disaster
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] most of you in
the process of designing games
will digitally incarnate
some form of mechanic
that [INAUDIBLE] that.
The player is going to say,
do I do the usual thumbs up
or do I start
[INAUDIBLE] the umbrella.
It will depend, of course.
If it's a game about health,
an umbrella won't be it, right?
It will be some other image.
But you get the point.
It's about the repetitive act.
The next slide, which I also
showed the previous group,
this is more what we want.
We want players to
experience an aha moment,
a moment of discovery that is
the result of the process where
they go though some not knowing
what the next choice is.
Otherwise, it would
be too obvious.
It would be [INAUDIBLE].
And [INAUDIBLE].
So good luck to all of you in
coming up with an [INAUDIBLE]
balance because huh and aha.
So moving on to
the next one, this
is about the first [INAUDIBLE].
It is in the context of this
game that you just played.
As I mentioned, when we
played with 200 people,
we can very quickly match
all the cards [INAUDIBLE]
by groups of three.
And we can quickly enter them
into a computer connected
to internet, [INAUDIBLE]
before and after,
so people can see at
the end of the workshop
how their own
thinking has changed.
Now, when we went through
the activity of Rick
pointing to a geometric,
choosing a word
like [INAUDIBLE], and other
people saying [INAUDIBLE].
If you have 50
people in the room,
it becomes much more difficult.
Because if you're doing
[INAUDIBLE], it becomes boring.
So what I ask you to consider
is to create a digital tool that
can be embedded or utilized
or employed to [INAUDIBLE],
so that we can collect
and process information
of what people are thinking.
So you'll be face to face,
just like you were then.
But I imagine that your
interface, this could be made
with 3,000 people [INAUDIBLE].
And then each [INAUDIBLE] works.
And there's some
game mechanic that
creates an incentive and
pitches [INAUDIBLE] at least
[INAUDIBLE] of the
time that helps
people visualize their result.
And that helps make
them analyze the data,
to assess the input to monitor
or to evaluate, and eventually
to [INAUDIBLE] this animation
of this [INAUDIBLE] concepting.
But folks, you have no
idea how much [INAUDIBLE]
was shouting at the first round.
[INAUDIBLE]
And you were so energized.
That's great.
We love that.
But we need to channel
that so it becomes
more useful to the subject.
So the chances [INAUDIBLE], if
you deliver something, and gain
a product life that works,
it's near guaranteed
that we will use it.
If your tool helps us
collect information
in a somewhat playful way, and
share it, and think about it,
we're going to use it.
And we're going to use
it in five continents,
starting the day
after you [INAUDIBLE].
And there are
researchers for this.
There are documents
that cover [INAUDIBLE]
called data
[INAUDIBLE] initiative.
And you can also consult
with me and [INAUDIBLE].
I should be here some
of the time if you
have any questions about it.
[INAUDIBLE] like what we did
for a tool similar to this one.
PROFESSOR 1: Was
that a question?
PROFESSOR 4: I
asked if you prefer
that we move on to the next
game idea, or if we pause
and invite for questions.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, let's do
questions after each idea,
just really briefly.
So any questions
about this game?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I thought we were
not supposed to make anything
that has to do with a network.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
So in this game,
there is a little bit
a networking going on.
If you were to do
this game, it would
mean it's not a multiplayer
networking experience.
But you are transmitting
data to some kind of server.
So that's where
this one gets hairy.
It looks like a simple
design, but it's actually
a bigger-- there's a bigger
back end to this one.
PROFESSOR 3: This is possibly,
just by looking at it fully,
it's possibly, technically,
the most difficult one.
Because it looks like it's
still a networking game,
even though we are
encouraging you to do
single players, single device.
PROFESSOR 1: And designing for
touch is very difficult too.
It just kind of it gets big.
Any other questions?
PROFESSOR 3: There
probably is a middle ground
where you can think
of, all right, what
can be done with a single
computer that would still
make it easier for
someone like Pablo
to be able to run this in
a workshop, for instance.
Even just making his
job slightly easier.
Remember, we just played this
game with imaginary things.
What can we do that
doesn't required
the players to have a
device, but speeds up
the process from
a central computer
to be able to say
collective data?
I don't know what
that would look like.
That would be more of a
design challenge, rather than
a technical challenge,
but possibly more feasible
for the size of this class.
PROFESSOR 4:
[INAUDIBLE] the results
are shared in real time.
But if people have
a cell phone, they
can just send an email to
the words to some address.
And then some
[INAUDIBLE] someone
punched buttons these
skills then. [INAUDIBLE].
Write down [INAUDIBLE] we don't
understand the [INAUDIBLE].
So as it was said before,
anything [INAUDIBLE] that you
may have to an
[INAUDIBLE] experience,
our to improve a [INAUDIBLE],
would be appreciated.
If no group chooses
this one, no problem.
PROFESSOR 1: So let's move one.
Actually Pablo, can you
turn off the screen sharing.
Maybe that will speed up the--
PROFESSOR 4: Oh, I wasn't
aware that I wasn't sharing.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, I
just noticed it too.
PROFESSOR 4: Here it
says I am not sharing.
Weird.
Let me go to this.
Stop sharing screen, good.
PROFESSOR 1: There we go.
So let's go to the next one.
PROFESSOR 4: The next
one is the important one.
It's the UNICEF Ghana.
UNICEF is the most
loved UN agency.
Well, I don't have [INAUDIBLE].
Generally speaking, it's fun for
a very well [INAUDIBLE] agency.
It works with
children and education
and it does very good
[INAUDIBLE] work.
And the team in
Ghana has decided
to reach out to [INAUDIBLE].
Originally it was in
the context of cholera.
But they also have some
money for Ebola and cholera.
And they want us to design
games for school children
that would help them
becoming familiar
with an improvement instrument
of risks [INAUDIBLE].
I have no contract yet.
But it's very likely
that this relationship
will grow, and will grow in
time, and will grow in size,
and will be able to get
into the digital very soon.
So the context is that cholera
is a waterborne disease
and is on the rise, in part
because of [INAUDIBLE], in part
because of the
organization, in part
because of the changing
character of flooding,
access to water, and so on.
It's almost [INAUDIBLE] risk
of getting cholera in countries
that the disease is epidemic.
There are [INAUDIBLE]
million cases every year.
And if you've never experienced
it, I can assure you,
it leads to a very
miserable experience.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] disease.
And of course it changes
from one year to the next.
But there's 100,000 people
dying out of cholera every year.
And that's not good.
And importantly,
many of those deaths
are avoidable if certain
measures are taken.
Some of those measures are
difficult. For example,
providing clean
water [INAUDIBLE]--
that is not something you
can do in five minutes.
But other things are
important and manageable.
For example, how
[INAUDIBLE] and protection
of water sources, or basic
hygiene and using soap--
many of those are simple.
So we have a money
project-- work
with some children in Ghana.
Rick will have all details of
the project and description.
The purpose is to help reduce
the risk of waterborne disease,
in particular, cholera.
The chances of risk are
very likely [INAUDIBLE]
something to be
further developed.
I would be very surprised
between and December
if [INAUDIBLE]
something [INAUDIBLE]
thousands and
thousands of children.
But if any of you
have the [INAUDIBLE]
clean, clear, useful
game [INAUDIBLE],
then maybe we can become
direct [INAUDIBLE]
or someone could be hired
with money [INAUDIBLE].
There's the cholera
toolkit, which if you pick--
show the next slide.
You see a [INAUDIBLE].
There's a chapter
1 program shown.
There are many stages.
There's the situation of
preventing how to coordinate,
how to prepare community
aspects, all sorts of things.
The toolkit [INAUDIBLE] is
extremely rich and detailed.
And we are now conversing with--
actually, we need two days.
We should be getting from
them, which are the thing that
the [INAUDIBLE] practice.
So who ever ends up
taking this challenge,
and we hope it
will be two groups,
it's going to be something
that very directly
capable of [INAUDIBLE] class.
And that must feel
good for whoever
successfully takes on that.
I do not remember the age group.
But I'm pretty sure it was
less than 18 and more than 10.
But it may be more
narrow than that.
I can't remember.
Ghana is an English
speaking country.
It in [INAUDIBLE] East Africa.
In terms of [INAUDIBLE],
the UNICEF team
works with [INAUDIBLE] games.
I'm going to pause here
and invite for questions.
PROFESSOR 1: Any
questions about this one?
OK, no questions on this one.
PROFESSOR 4: Very good.
Was I very boring or very clear?
Moving on to the next one.
If you're having
[INAUDIBLE] slide show,
you can see through the text?
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 4: Good.
So this one is linking early
warning with early action.
Science [INAUDIBLE] progress
of something [INAUDIBLE]
likely to accompany
[INAUDIBLE] future.
And there are
timescales that are
going to be at the seasonal
level, like El Nino,
and weeks to months.
We're more likely to
focus on it hours to days.
And in the meantime, in
the case of [INAUDIBLE]
that's very useful, but
there is a lot being done.
In the case of heatwaves,
that's not very much lower.
An issue with heatwaves
is on one hand because
of global warming and
the changing climate,
the recent heatwaves is
very steep [INAUDIBLE].
You need to remember
from almost a decade ago,
Netherlands, France, Belgium,
they have tens of thousands
of people die
because of the heat.
And most of those people die for
very, very avoidable reasons.
So if you're elderly, or
have respiratory problems,
you have certain legal health
condition, very simple things
like being in a colder
room with your condition
or drinking more than you
want, that alone can be enough.
Construction workers
[INAUDIBLE] sports collapse.
All you have to do is to
suspend the competition,
or to [INAUDIBLE].
So it's very [INAUDIBLE]
and consistently take people
by surprise.
So the purpose of
these games will
be to support Red Cross,
especially as a [INAUDIBLE].
So they can learn what are
the simple actions taken
to save lives, not only at
home but more importantly,
the lives of [INAUDIBLE]
members of the community.
The chance for the [INAUDIBLE]
also is pretty big.
But it's a little bit
more of a timeline.
So it will begin-- we
start looking in January.
We will need some [INAUDIBLE].
But there are some
institutional needs to embed.
Once they exist, it has to go
through Red Cross channels,
which can be more complicated
than going in through school
children, where if it is
picked, it goes viral quickly.
But it's still a very good one.
Again, it's one that can
lead to saving real lives.
And there plenty of resources
within the Red Cross
and beyond.
Importantly, there is a
master's student at Harvard
who is doing her
entire thesis on this.
And we're going to
have at least one,
maybe two, hack-a-thons
dealing with heatwave risk.
The Harvard student,
her name is Elle.
She's really great fun.
And she would be a collaborator.
And this will have a lot
of chances of growth.
If you did see a photo from
the Netherlands heatwave,
and Red Cross volunteer helping
an elderly lady just hydrate,
and do that lady did not die,
whereas tens of thousands did.
Can you come up with a
game that helps people
make such simple decisions?
And I'm sure there's
a way to make it fun.
So overview-- one
or two questions?
PROFESSOR 1: Any
questions on this one?
So the target audience
on this one's different.
It's Red Cross
volunteers and staffers.
It's probably as part
of their training?
PROFESSOR 4: Correct.
So the way we envision this--
actually I dind't mention--
the way you envisions this one
is to have the game as ready,
deployable but on the shelf.
And then when there's a forecast
of a heatwave likely to happen
over the coming six days,
then we blast the game
to the Red Cross volunteers.
So they become very quickly
familiar with the very core
aspect of it, of course
complemented with others
like maybe face to face
training, or mainly sending
documents to read But this
would be potentially very
easy to adapt or translate
to many languages.
And again, Chicago,
Boston-- there's
plenty of places even in the US.
This is the one that would be
easiest to play test locally
because we can-- And the
profile of a Red Cross volunteer
is not necessarily too different
from the profile of university
students who are engaged
in do-good activities.
PROFESSOR 1: OK,
on to the next one.
PROFESSOR 4: All right,
moving to the next one.
The next one is
the most complex.
Do you see the drawing of
the time bomb with the fuse?
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
PROFESSOR 4: OK.
So allow me to give a
little bit of context.
We did a little bit
of this conversation
when I showed up
a few weeks ago,
but I imagine you
all forgot by now.
The humanitarian sector has
two main funding mechanisms.
Imagine a pot of money.
Even if there's almost no
money there, if the pot exists,
money can go in, to then
be taken out to spend.
One of the pots of money that
exists, one of the funding
mechanisms that exists
is for disaster response,
meaning a hurricane,
flood, volcanic eruption.
Something has already
happened, is happening,
and is killing people.
People are dying, but
if you did something,
you could save lives.
For example, get on a
boat and rescue people
who are stranded on a roof.
Or people are sick.
Go give them medicine.
This is disaster response.
And if you spend money, you
can do very good things.
And the funding
mechanism exists.
There is another pot of money
which is for a normal days.
The Red Cross has vehicles.
The vehicles needs maintenance.
They need to change tires.
You need to buy a new computer.
You need to pay rent and
the electricity bills.
You need to train staff.
So on a normal day, you have a
budget for either maintenance,
or development of new
projects, or writing proposals,
and so on.
And when that pot
of money exists,
we called it the annual appeal.
Every year, we appeal for help.
And people or donors, or
governments give us some money.
What does not exists is what
the drawing of the cartoon
depicts, which is when there
is a signal from science
that a disasters, that something
bad is likely to happen soon.
We don't have money to fund
action before the disaster,
after the forecast.
So if you click to see
the text, the context
is that there that
missing money part.
We have money for
after a disaster,
we have money for
everyone all day.
But we don't have money
for before the disaster,
after the forecast.
The issue is that if you spend
money in that time window,
before the disaster
and after the scientist
says a disaster
is likely, you can
do very good things for
very cheap, and relatively
simply, and much more reliably.
It's not only more
expensive, but more
difficult to save a life when
the storm waters are flashing
through a city and people
are above the ground.
The boat is unstable.
Whereas if you do
it the day before,
when the water has
come down from the sky
but it's still in the
river and not in the city,
people can take action
by just walking away,
on your own means,
with your valuables
and not just depending on
someone to show up with a boat.
So we came up with a
financial mechanism,
we call it
forecast-based financing
for disaster preparedness
which is nuanced
in how it's implemented.
There is a pot of money.
It's like a bank account.
You need to have a
threshold of disaster risk
that needs to be exceeded.
So it can not be
two drops of rain.
It has to be a lot of rain.
It can not be some wind.
It has to be a hurricane
category 1 or more.
But once the threshold is
established and reached
by the forecast, then there's
some standard operating
procedures, some actions
that people have to take,
spending money to save lives.
And that is something
that if you could come up
with a game that captures that,
this is the one that if we help
communicate
forecast-based financing,
I sent to a colleague because
it can work for a broad audience
digitally.
Ideally we would reach those
who can contribute either money
or decisions, muscle power.
The chances of
embrace for this one
are not as high as
on the previous one.
But if it were to happen,
it'll have the highest impact.
Because right now there's
billions of dollars being
spent in the two extremes.
And in the small fraction
where spent investigating
that precious window
of opportunity--
when you see that fuse getting
close, that time of effort
can really have a
very, very high impact.
There's a link to
a journal article
that should be very
clear for MIT students.
We also have some simpler
readings and journal
[INAUDIBLE] I have been engaged
within and are ready to help.
This is, I insist,
the one that is
intellectually most challenging.
But I think if you
nail it, it will also
be the most rewarding.
Questions?
PROFESSOR 1: Any
questions on this one?
So one thing, when we first
started designing this class,
this is actually the problem
that we're most interested in,
mainly because the
other problems,
we just hadn't
heard about since.
Cholera was a recent proposal
that was asked for, and Ebola,
of course, very,
very recent as well.
So if you really enjoyed
some of the challenges
from projects 2 and
3, and you really
took on the planning
aspects, the trade
offs aspects of those
two games, if you're
looking at trying to
communicate to another person
how these probabilities
works, this
is probably a
really good project
you might be interested in.
PROFESSOR 4: And I
should say also I'm
working with a few MIT teams,
including the Humanitarian
Response Lab, including the
Environmental Engineering.
We have two generations
of three students
plus one professor
going to Uganda to work
on making this happen for real.
We got German money to do
it in Togo and in Uganda.
So it's been meaning to happen.
But it's hard to explain
because it's dry.
It's like explaining insurance.
People get bored
before they get it.
So maybe a game can
help launch it a bit.
Good.
Then we'll move on.
Number 4, Ebola.
And I have to be very candid.
I come from climate research,
climate and disasters.
And as far as we
know, Ebola does not
have much of a climate signal.
But, as I'm sure you know,
it's a very importantly thing.
And the idea for
bringing this up
is that one of my
[INAUDIBLE] colleagues,
Steven Ryan one day
sent a message saying,
tonight I'm arriving in Liberia
to work for a month with a Red
Cross national team that is
doing it's best to respond
to the Ebola outbreak.
And guess what?
What they're doing, as
its best, is not enough.
Steven is a
communications specialist.
As you can imagine, I
feel phenomenal admiration
and respect for his dangerous
choice to go to the place
where people are in very
serious trouble to try to help.
And that made me think,
well, maybe we can help.
So I sent him an
email, and he kindly
responded saying, yes, they're
keen on the possibility
of a game.
Bear in mind that because
of the cycle of the disease,
by December chances
are that either it
became a complete pandemic,
or they [INAUDIBLE]
is completely gone.
So we are not going
to make a game
to be played in the equivalent
situation as the situation now.
It would be more of a game about
an awareness of how it works
and how it can be prevent
in a hopefully less
than complete crisis mode.
But nonetheless, Steven
and one of his colleagues
were very graceful
to offer themselves
to be the subject matter
experts and to help,
should a team choose Ebola--
please no more than one team.
There's someone on the other
side of Atlantic Ocean that
is going to try to engage.
In this one, John and I
do not have expertise.
I imagine it is possible to find
expertise in the Boston area
with so many phenomenal
hospitals and so on.
But it's outside of my control
to offer reliable support when
it comes to subject matter.
I'm sure that there's plenty
of documents from the CDC
and from health
practitioners that
can help you design a game.
But whoever chooses
this, it'll be heroic.
It can be really useful.
But you have to be most
prepared to work autonomously.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR 1: Any?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 4: Are you guys there?
PROFESSOR 1: Sorry, I
had the microphone muted.
No questions on this one.
PROFESSOR 4: So moving
on to the last one.
If [INAUDIBLE]
hasn't joined yet,
then I'll do my best to explain.
PROFESSOR 1: Yup, I
haven't seen her yet.
PROFESSOR 4: So
this is a project
that is being led by
two of my colleagues,
including [INAUDIBLE].
So forgive my ignorance.
And it's very similar in its
nature to the UNICEF one.
The difference is that
the UNICEF project
is for small children about a
very specific health condition
called cholera.
Whereas this one
is for a partner
called Plan International.
It's an NGO that
works with children.
They're very good.
They work a lot on the
rights of children.
They are about empowerment.
And they work intelligently.
And the Asian team has reached
out to the planning center.
And I don't if you
can read the words,
but in summary we want a
game to help children in Asia
understand climate
change and what
can be done to adapt
to climate change.
Plan International seeks to
partner with the Red Cross
[INAUDIBLE] Planning
Center to develop
a participatory learning
game for children in Asia,
focus on Southeast Asia.
So all the way from
[INAUDIBLE] Cambodia,
et cetera, that would
strengthen their understanding
of local climate change
impacts, and help them
develop a [INAUDIBLE] what
they and their community
can do to adapt and
increase their resilience.
The project will include
the [INAUDIBLE] game
package, testing, and a
training officer [INAUDIBLE].
The current project does not
include a digital component
because there
wasn't enough money.
But like the UNICEF
one, this is an area
that inevitably has to grow.
So if any of you comes
up with a prototype that
is sufficiently playable to
capture something about climate
change, there's
generally two [INAUDIBLE]
ideas that children can
benefit from learning.
One is that the trends
of change are dangerous.
[INAUDIBLE] sea level
rise, like drying
of some sources of drinking
water, as well as the changing
pattern of extreme events,
which can be about rainfall,
can be about temperature, can
be about the winds and cyclones.
And so children who
have not lived long,
and therefore don't
have much of a memory,
are likely to have to
confront information
about things, extreme
events, disasters
that they've never
experienced, but they
have to do something about.
So the game is not about
one specific threat,
but is more about the
concept of adaptation
to planet change, which
of course can be embedded
into a specific manifestation
of planet change,
like sea level rise, or like
changing rainfall patterns.
There was a more clearly
defined age group
for this one, which
unfortunately I don't
have off the top of my head.
But [INAUDIBLE] will be sending
the materials to the team.
So within 24 hours, I
pray that you will have
all the ingredients you need.
I know I didn't share too much.
But are there any questions
about what I could share?
PROFESSOR 1: Any
questions about this one?
No questions on this one.
PROFESSOR 4: OK.
Then move onto the next slide.
We have about 50 minutes
left [INAUDIBLE].
And based on some
questions and comments,
I'd like to get a
[INAUDIBLE] front room.
You have all choices here.
The first one was snap.
I need a digital tool to
enhance the snap experience
of collecting and
processing information.
Then we have the
UNICEF Ghana, Cholera,
where we hope we can get
two groups because this
is a big one.
Then we have linking early
warning and early action
maybe focusing on heatwaves.
Then we have the more
sophisticated, conceptually,
[INAUDIBLE] forecast-based
financing, funding mechanisms
for disaster preparedness
before the disaster,
after the forecast.
And then we have Ebola,
where there's not
much I can offer other
than if you make a game,
we can try to hook
you up with people.
And if you come up with a good
game, it can be really useful.
And the final one is
adaptation to climate change
to be played by children
in Southeast Asia
so that they understand
climate change.
Here's what I propose.
We're going to give
you guys 30 seconds.
Each one of you choose
one or two secretly
based on what [INAUDIBLE]
which is completely
incomplete information.
But that's the way it is.
Given what you've
heard, choose one or two
of those in the
come 10, 15 seconds.
I'll give you that time.
Thanks for your patience.
PROFESSOR 1: Not a problem.
PROFESSOR 4: And
so what we're going
to do now is-- you're
all sitting I imagine.
Actually Rick, can
you show the room?
PROFESSOR 1: Let me
go back to the Skype
and turn on our video.
PROFESSOR 4: So what I
want to do is [INAUDIBLE],
and if that number
of your chosen one,
I want you to do two things.
One is to stand up, the
other to shout snap.
But I cannot see everyone.
I cannot hear everyone.
But it will give me a
flavor of proportion.
So item 0, if you're ready
to [INAUDIBLE] stand up,
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 4: All
right, so we've got
maybe one in four [INAUDIBLE].
Excellent.
You may sit down.
Number 1, if it's of
your liking, do it?
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 4: All right.
Good.
This one, [INAUDIBLE] all
of you guys on a group
because I don't see
enough for two groups.
[INAUDIBLE]
Then next one now, for two.
If you're going to do, do it.
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 4: All right.
This one seems popular.
Number 3, go.
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 4: Thank you.
Number 4, show it.
PROFESSOR 1: 4 was
the funding one?
PROFESSOR 4: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Three was
the funding one.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: Yup, you're right.
I'm wrong.
Yeah, we're counting from 0.
4 is Ebola.
So nobody stood up for this one.
PROFESSOR 4: OK.
And if [INAUDIBLE] do
the last one, number 5.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Snap.
PROFESSOR 4: OK, so
we're focused then.
I don't know, Rick
and team, what
you had in mind for this time.
But given that we
went relatively fast,
what we could do
is you could point
to different places of the
room and talk [INAUDIBLE]
0 middle, left is 1, and so on.
And invite people to just
answer with your feet.
Which is the location
they most want to go to?
So we get a sense
of how many people
want to engage in which game.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
So we've got it on the board.
Cholera here, Ebola
here, early warning here.
These are actually
behind you, so I'm going
to have to rotate the computer.
Snap over there,
adaptation here,
and disaster prep funding,
the forecast-based funding
over here.
PROFESSOR 3: Let's draw
out the numbers as well.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh yeah,
I'll put the numbers up.
PROFESSOR 3: So snap
was 0, cholera was 1,
early warning was 2,
funding was 3, Ebola was 4,
and adaptation to
climate change, 5.
PROFESSOR 4: So
answer with your feet.
You can not stay
sitting for [INAUDIBLE].
And now Rick and team,
I'm going to invite you,
because you know best what
is required for each group,
be it finance grouping, in
terms of quantity of people,
in terms of profile
[INAUDIBLE], there
won't be code geeks
in one, and then
narrative geeks on the other.
If you understand this,
at least what happens now
is in now way definitive.
But it's to get a
sense [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
So actually this
leads really well
into what we're about to do.
We're going to do some
brainstorming on these topics.
So we're going to first
have each of the groups
just do a little bit of a quick
brainstorming about the topic
that they're standing
with right now.
And then midway
through, we're going
to invite you to go
over to a new group
to talk about a
different project
if you're interested in talking
about that other project.
On Monday, we're going
to actually form the team
and make sure all the teams
meet our requirements.
But it's basically seven
to eight people per team.
We're hoping for
eight people per team,
hopefully not more than that.
But we'll figure
that out as we go.
And over the weekend, we'll
be using the mailing list
to talk about the projects.
So I'm actually going to
let-- we're going to start off
with this brainstorming.
We're going to
take a break, we're
going to do some
more brainstorming.
And then I will
more clearly outline
how the mechanism is going to
work between now and Monday.
PROFESSOR 4: Do you
need me to stay online.
PROFESSOR 1: No.
What we would like
is-- are you going
to be on email between
now and Monday?
PROFESSOR 4: Yes, but only
with very limited ability
to read and respond.
So make sure to make the
subject line very clear
and the questions as snappy
and answerable as possible.
PROFESSOR 1: And you don't
mind if give all the teams
your email address?
PROFESSOR 4: No mind-- but
teams, please, please, please,
I beg you, consolidate
your questions.
Be very efficient
with your writing.
Because if I get too many
emails or too wordy, excessive
verbosity, I will not
be able to get it.
PROFESSOR 1: So I'll
figure out a mechanism--
PROFESSOR 4: [INAUDIBLE] fine,
a channel within each group
to communicate and consolidate.
PROFESSOR 1: So I'll
figure out a mechanism
to make sure you're not
overloaded with email,
and to make sure everyone gets
the benefits of those emails
to you.
PROFESSOR 4: Good.
And I suggest that you
always copy [INAUDIBLE].
All right, so good
luck to you all.
Thanks again for your
time and inspiration.
And I wish you good
luck [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
Thank you Pablo.
OK so you're in your groups.
I have paper for people
who are not on chalkboards.
Do we have nobody for Ebola?
PROFESSOR 3: No one.
PROFESSOR 1: Then let's give
snap the Ebola-- actually
you're pretty big.
Let's not.
These two groups are pretty big.
Let's give them
space to spread out.
So what we're going to do is
just a really quick brainstorm.
Five minutes-- just choose
one person to be a secretary.
Have them come up.
You've heard a little
bit about the topics.
You haven't done any
of the reading yet.
We're going to have all that
reading available for you
on Stellar right now for you
to read over the weekend.
It's a lot of it.
We don't expect you
to read all of it.
But we do expect
you to look at it.
Based on what you understand,
what kind of mechanics
could come out of
these kind of topics?
Just based on the
word cholera, based
on the word early
warning, early action,
what kind of game
mechanics pop out of that?
And just through
them on the board.
So disaster prep-- let me
hand these off to those two.
PROFESSOR 3: To disaster prep,
or to more than one group?
PROFESSOR 1: One to one,
and one to the other.
PROFESSOR 3: We had a question
like that, by the way.
Rick, we have
questions in the back.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, one second.
What's the question?
From who?
PROFESSOR 3: Let's
stick it up on the wall?
PROFESSOR 1: What's up?
PROFESSOR 3: You guys
probably need the stand.
STUDENT 13: What game engines
would-- is it the same
as other previous ones?
PROFESSOR 1: Same
as previous ones.
We'll talk about the
constraints on Monday.
Don't worry about the
constraints right now.
Right now just focus
on game mechanics.
STUDENT 13: [INAUDIBLE]
mobile [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah,
so keep it blue sky.
You can be mobile.
You can be on tablets,
you could be a computer.
It could be single player,
it could be multiplayer.
Just don't do
multiplayer networking.
That's it.
STUDENT 13: Our game has--
PROFESSOR 1: What's that?
Our game's definition
is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Then what are the
ways you're going to get around
that like we talked about?
STUDENT 13: Without
doing multiplayer?
PROFESSOR 1: Without doing
multiple devices connecting
to a single server.
There's other ways.
Don't even think about it
for this brainstorming.
Just don't worry
about it for now.
Here we go.
Pass these out.
All right, so five minutes, go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: This is in
case my wife sends pictures.
So I have another
group that we work
with is doing an EdX course.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: We've done
about 15 minutes of really
quick and dirty brainstorming.
Somebody from your group
shout out one or two
really, really interesting
idea that you're really
excited about.
Just one person, one group,
interesting ideas, this group
go.
STUDENT 14: Spatial
placement of wells affecting
where cholera spreads.
PROFESSOR 1: So
spatial placement
of wells affecting
where cholera spreads?
STUDENT 14: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
So a spatial puzzle
kind of game.
STUDENT 14: Exactly.
PROFESSOR 1: One more idea?
STUDENT 15: Animal crossing
with cholera and puzzles.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes,
animal crossing.
I'd think about the
scope on that one.
STUDENT 16: Playing
as a heatwave.
PROFESSOR 1: Playing
as the heatwave,
you are the heatwave, cool.
One other idea?
STUDENT 17: Playing
as a Red Cross
volunteer, managing resources.
PROFESSOR 1: OK, not as cool.
Heatwave [INAUDIBLE] volunteer.
Over here.
STUDENT 18: You're
on a tiny island
and you live on the island and
you do stuff on the island.
But your island is shrinking.
So you have to collect
resources on your island
to move to the bigger island.
The bigger island
is shrinking too
because the water
keeps going up.
So you hop, and hop, and hop,
and you arrive at the mainland.
Yay, everyone's saved!
Except the mainland
is a giant island too.
Whaa, whaa, whaa.
PROFESSOR 1: Whaa,
whaa, climate change.
Cool.
Thank you.
Another idea, or is
that the big one?
STUDENT 19: The decision
between chopping forests
and to build more buildings
for faster development,
or to keep the
forest air help make
climate change less severe.
PROFESSOR 1: Cool.
So one's kind of, you
don't have much action.
The world is going around you.
This one is kind
of, you have action.
The decisions you make are
going to affect things.
Cool.
This group here?
This was snap right, this group?
One or two ideas?
STUDENT 20: Well,
so I was thinking
about not just choosing
words, but given a scenario,
making a particular decision
can vary in two decisions
other people made given that
exact same set of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: OK,
so really thinking
about how you're going to
make this simple decision,
or this simple interaction
that the game has,
make it a little
bit more complex
and really kind of bring
the decision making out
in the forefront-- is that
kind of what it sounds like?
Right?
Yeah, what's up?
STUDENT 21: The was I
understood the game,
or the description
for snap is that it's
more of a data
collection method,
like collecting what people--
PROFESSOR 1: That's at least
the purpose they want, is they
want that data.
Well they want to
collect that data.
But they also want to
reflect that data back.
So it's a little bit
of a visualization.
It's actually a of
a visualization,
as much as it is collection.
Are those the only groups,
or the only concepts?
Oh yeah, disaster preparedness.
Everybody's disappeared.
Anybody from that group want
to run over to the sheet
and say an idea or two?
Or you just kind of--
STUDENT 22: I think we just
got stuck on the brainstorming
because the program
is not as easy.
PROFESSOR 1: So it's hard.
It's going to be a hard one.
STUDENT 23: One idea we
came up with was building
an infrastructure
and you would decide
whether to keep expanding or
to reinforce the structure.
And that way, you
would oh, are you
preparing for before the
disaster or after the disaster.
Did you have something to add?
STUDENT 24: I was
just going to say
we felt like we needed to do
more reading to understand
exactly what [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: But
something about there
is something that can be
built to spend that money on.
So it's not just about
collecting the money,
it's that money's
going to go somewhere.
Which I remember him
saying at least--
I don't know if it
was a meeting with me,
or if it was one of the first
times he came to class to talk.
But I remember that came up.
Take a quick couple
minutes, one person
from each group make a copy
of all the ideas you have
on the board somehow,
like a photograph,
or-- actually just take
a photograph of it,
and then come back
to your seats.
We've got two more slides, then
we're going to release you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: So after you've
taken your captures, sit down.
What next?
I'm going to stand
in front because I
can't see what my slides say.
So today we brainstormed
in groups on these topics.
Between now and Monday,
what we'd like you to do
is use the mailing list, the
videogames@mit.edu at mailing
list to form teams.
In class on Monday,
we will actually also
set aside time in the
beginning of class
to make sure that all
these teams get formed.
And we're going to do some more
brainstorming and some more
pitching on Monday.
And I'll go into more detail
about the requirements
for the project 4.
But make sure you read
the project 4 assignment.
That's basically all I'm going
to be doing is just saying
out loud what it says in there.
So before next class,
do these things.
Read the material in Stellar.
All the topics have some
material in Stellar.
The Ebola topic did not,
the snap topic did not,
but cholera has the
tool kit that he'd
that he mentioned up there.
Early warning, early action has
a like a task force guideline,
like a idea of world
disasters from 2009, I think.
And then another
journal article.
Disaster prep funding has that
forecast-based funding journal
article attached to it.
Adaptation for
climate change, we
don't have materials
yet for that.
But that should be
coming in today.
And that'll be put
up into Stellar.
That's all of that, right?
So when you're in your groups,
think about these questions.
And think about these
questions until Monday.
Did you actually have eight
people interested in your topic
when you were in your group
together, like think back
about the brainstorming.
Did you see seven
other individuals
interested in the topic?
If you did, you can
probably make a game
based on that topic.
If you didn't, it's going
to be difficult to find
people for your team.
So really use the
mailing list and try
to figure out ways
to use the mailing
to try to attract
people to your topic.
If there's something
about like the game design
that you came up,
a personal reason
why you'd like to
see this game get
made, throw it to
the mailing list.
If you really don't care
about the topic so much
or any of these topics, but you
really want to do programming,
you really want to
do art, you really
want to do code,
whatever you want
to do, if that's the thing
that you're most interested in,
that game engine
you want to use,
throw an email to the
class to say, hey, use me.
Here's what I'm
interested in doing.
Put me on your team, basically.
If you're more interested in the
mechanic design over the topic,
that's also OK.
So you might not be
interested in the topic,
but you're interested in
some of these mechanics
that we've been talking about in
class, or some of the mechanics
that you heard mentioned
in the group brainstorms,
so mention that in mailing list.
Again, team information
will be finalized on Monday.
And if you are
undecided, I'm just
going to stick you in a team.
That's the worst thing
that could happen.
Because if I just
put you in a team,
I'm not thinking about who
you're going to work best with.
I'm not thinking about what
game engine you're working on.
I'm not thinking about
is whether or not you're
interested in the topic or not.
I'm just grabbing you, and
sticking you on a team.
So do all the work for me,
so I don't have to do that.
And if you do just want
me to do that, that's OK.
I like rolling dice.
Do we have any questions about
this, any concerns about this?
Yes.
STUDENT 25: Are you
targeting five teams?
PROFESSOR 1: No, I'm
targeting teams of eight.
So that's five teams, but
it could be four teams if we
need more people on the teams.
I would recommend 10
being your biggest cap.
In the past, we have seen
10 person teams work-ish.
They failed everywhere you
think they failed, communication
largely, scheduling largely.
The one thing they
didn't have that I
think you're more
prepared to do,
if you were in a
big team like that,
is that they didn't understand
how to break out the strike
groups, into strike teams,
how to separate tasks and form
into smaller groups.
I've actually seen you all
do this on these previous two
projects.
So if you do find
yourself in a large team,
think about how you're
going to break the work up
into the small tasks, into these
bigger, modular kind of things.
Especially think about
why you're in this class.
What did you expect to
get out of this class?
What do you expect to get
out of this final project?
If you wanted to do some
really big tech thing,
there are some ideas out here
that require some heavy tech
lifting.
If you're in designer, there's
some really, really challenging
design issues, especially with
that forecast-based funding.
I'm really leaving
that up to you.
But I'm going to make sure
that all the teams have
eight people.
Any other questions?
PROFESSOR 3: Just one
statement [INAUDIBLE].
Especially with
the snap team, I do
realize that as
presented to you today,
it really does seem
like a networking game.
That really does seem
like a game that will
involve a lot of networking.
And of course, we've
spent the entire semester
so far telling you, oh
good lord, don't do that.
So it could be a
huge tech challenge,
or it could be a huge
design challenge.
The huge design challenge is
how do you accomplish everything
that we think we need
networking to accomplish
without networking.
Or it could be a tech
challenge that's, screw it,
we're going to do networking.
Then it becomes what's the least
brittle way to accomplish that.
The problem with networking
and that particular game
is that to require
networking means
that you need to play this
game in a room with networking.
Which means if you take it
to a room without Wi-Fi,
for instance, that means it's
got to be something that's
going to work over
a phone system,
or it's going to
require short messages,
or something ridiculous.
And if you don't
have networking,
it's going to be like, what
are you going to be doing.
Are you going to point
a camera in a room
and do image capture,
or something?
It's like some crazy
things-- are you
going to do manual data entry?
That's actually a possibility.
Anything that you
can come up with that
makes that game that we played
in class slightly easier
might be beneficial for Pablo.
And he's guaranteed
that he will use it
as soon as you provide it.
So that's an
incentive right there.
But it is possibly,
despite how simple
that game is, possibly
one of the toughest design
challenges that I can
see on the board today.
PROFESSOR 1: Up
until now, we've been
really strict in allowing
you to use specific tools,
use specific methods.
We're going to start easing up.
But if you break any of the
rules, you need to tell us why.
That's all we ask.
If you are going to use
multiplayer, tell us why.
If you're not going to use
one of these game engines
that we've been practicing
on for this semester, really,
you really need to convince us.
So use the office hours
like [? Sarah ?] suggested.
Use the mailing list.
Talk to us during class.
I've already had
quite a few students
talk to me individually, and
talk to them individually
about these kinds of thing.
The rules are
there to be broken.
But don't break all
of them at once.
Break one.
PROFESSOR 3: If you're going
to get rid of like the task
list or something like that,
what are you replacing it with?
Tell us if you're going to
be not doing daily scrums
because it doesn't
work for your team.
What are you replacing that
communication strategy with?
Because it's clearly there
for a particular reason.
Hopefully you've
seen the reason,
even if you haven't
necessarily managed to make
it work on a previous team.
So what are you going
to do in its place?
Sarah, did you want to--
PROFESSOR 2: I think
you guys covered it all.
About all I can do is
restate the [INAUDIBLE]
about breaking rules.
And it's break rules with care.
We didn't give them to
you just to be arbitrary.
We gave them to you
in our experience
of watching a lot of
students make a lot of games,
and make a lot of mistakes.
These are the big pits
that people dig themselves
in and then climb
down and wonder
what the heck they're doing in.
So if you're going to break
a rule, have a plan for it .
Come and talk to us
about whether or not
you think your plan will work.
We are here to try and
support, and give you advice,
and help out.
PROFESSOR 3: I think it's
fair to say that we've
seen every single rule that we
provided actually successfully
broken in every single year.
Not all the time--
PROFESSOR 1: Except
for that bad year.
PROFESSOR 3: The what?
PROFESSOR 1: Except
for that bad year.
PROFESSOR 3: Except
for that one bad year
where every project was crap.
PROFESSOR 2: Don't be that year.
PROFESSOR 1: No,
you're not that year.
PROFESSOR 2: You're
not that year.
PROFESSOR 1: And Paulina
was in the class last year.
So if you're looking
for student level, what
was it like during this
project, talk to Paulina.
She can help you out.
She can give you some tips.
And talk to each other.
That's why we do all
these presentations.
Yes.
STUDENT 26: What level of
polishedness [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 1: We're going to talk
about that through for the rest
of the semester.
What does polish mean?
Polished, to our eyes-- I'll
talk about this on Monday.
But basically what we're
asking for is the games you've
made these past two
projects, that's
about the scope you should
have think for project 4.
So if you thinking about
that kind of scope,
but then you have
four times the time,
what are you applying
that time towards?
Polish and making sure
the user experience is
easy to use-- it doesn't
crash, it doesn't break.
A player can start
playing and figure out
through the systems
of the game how
it works, what the keys are.
You've got good credit screens.
We're not necessarily asking for
an art, sound, or music polish.
We're not asking
for indie level art.
We're asking for just
a level below that.
A unified level of polish--
so everything in the game
has the same amount of time,
care, effort being put into it.
PROFESSOR 3: It doesn't
feel uneven and bumpy.
It doesn't feel like, here's
this awesome soundtrack
with this really,
really terrible art.
Or here's this really
bleepy, 8-bit thing
with gorgeous,
hand-painted scenery.
That's not cohesive.
We want everything
to look like it's
on an even level of quality.
PROFESSOR 1: This might be a
preview for future lectures,
but play Ponycorns.
Look up the term Ponycorn.
It's a game made by a
five-year-old and her father.
That is actually a
high level of polish
that I've seen
happen in this class.
If it happens with your project,
it would be really great.
Yes, Sissy's Magical
Ponycorn Adventure.
PROFESSOR 2: The key
thing to note here
is that all the assets were
created by the five year old.
And I believe the story was also
written by the five year old.
PROFESSOR 1: And the sounds.
PROFESSOR 2: And the
sounds were done by her.
And her father just did all the
coding and put it all together.
PROFESSOR 1: What's that?
STUDENT 27: $3,199
in donations to date.
PROFESSOR 2: If you can draw
as well as a five year old,
you can make good
assets for you game.
PROFESSOR 1: So we've
got nine minutes left
for the rest of class.
Capture all the ideas
that you wrote down
and mail them to
videogames@mit.edu.
So whoever took a capture
of each of these things,
just turn it into a
text file, and mail it.
Yeah?
STUDENT 28: Somebody created
a Google spreadsheet.
Can we all just put
our pictures in there?
PROFESSOR 1: That's fine.
STUDENT 28: So we don't
get million emails.
PROFESSOR 1: Absolutely.
PROFESSOR 3: Also there
are a couple of students
who aren't in class today.
So they may need some-- you
might need to sort of explain
to them what happened
today and bring them up
to speed, especially if
you are like dormmates,
or hallmates or
something like that.
Please help them along
and help them get ready
so that by Monday-- get the
conversation going on online so
that they can at least
have a clue of which
team to join on Monday.
PROFESSOR 1: The rest
of the time is yours.